welcome to Table Talk my name is Brett
pastor at the table and today I want to
talk about three ways not to pray like
many of you for years and years and
years I was terrible at praying
beginning in my teens I decided that I
loved God and I was gonna pray but
honestly it was just kind of boring my
mind was too Restless so I decided well
I'm just not much of a prayer but then I
went to my first year of college and I
decided that would be the year I would
learn to pray and be awesome at it and
so I locked myself in a room for an hour
a day and I prayed I pray that nations
would be shaken I pray that that I would
be utterly transformed by the love of
God I prayed that miracles would flow
from my fingertips I was very extreme
and let me tell you um didn't really
work I saw no vision I heard no audible
voice no miracles occurred and at least
as far as I knew it was just a failure
and honestly I became hacked off and
bitter now look you back it's a little
funny cuz this is like a classically
immature way to approach God hey God
you're gonna get on my page you're gonna
get on on my terms and here's what I
want to see it was we'll just say
incredibly misguided and as far as I can
tell I made at least three mistakes in
that season of trying to learn to pray
maybe these can help you number one I
tried to go too long jesus said when you
pray pray like this our Father who is in
heaven holy be your name then he goes on
to say a prayer that basically takes all
of 60 to 90 seconds to pray or you have
Saint Benedict he was a man who's
influenced the spiritual lives of
millions of Christians over the last
thousand years and he put it this way
prayer should therefore be short impure
unless perhaps it is prolonged under the
inspiration of divine grace so there you
have it from Jesus and all st. Benedict
don't start out with some in
ambition to pray for an hour a day so
that was my first mistake too long
second I tried to be too serious
my whole demeanor was slightly ferocious
I was going to conquer this praying
thing by golly no look if anything will
humble you it will be praying because
the mind is like a cage full of monkeys
look it's just better to relax to smile
a bit have a slightly humorous
relationship with yourself and your
praying
third I had too high of expectations the
world and I were going to be transformed
through my praying I was going to shake
the nation's I was going to transform
the world and myself and everyone and
everything around me it was like oh my
gosh what what is going on bread like
too high of expectations so what's the
answer I think the answer is to you
simply expect this through prayer you
will learn to love that's it
like if miracles happen awesome if the
nations are shaken amazing but at the
end of the day praying it can't be just
about all of that all of those big
things and honestly there can be a lot
of ego in that like it's kind of just
all about me right wanting to look
spiritual wanting to be spiritual
wanting to be a man of God and it's a
really pray truly there's got to be a
certain humility so I say lower the
expectations and simply ask God to
deepen your love for him all right so
when you pray imagine love is flowing
out from you towards God and when you
pray for others
imagine that love is flowing out from
you towards them and when you pray for
yourself imagine love and compassion
flowing into your very body right this
is this is is prayer
as learning to love well and as I think
back on all those years ago I would have
been so much better off to go into that
year of learning to pray simply with the
expectation that I would learn to love a
little better and that each time I pray
just a bit of the evil that is in me
would be removed and transformed by the
love of God so I hope that's helpful
three mistakes I made when praying I
hope you can avoid them dear friends so
that's all for today if you like this
video please like and share and comment
and subscribe have a good one
grace and peace